bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo bonjour aux deux bras qui nique à
libourne est toute l'actualité politique
et parlementaire évidemment on va
commencer par cette dernière ligne
droite pour les primaires françois
hollande et martine aubry se
départageront ce dimanche une semaine
d'entre deux tours marqué par les
soutien à françois hollande et par le
dernier débat télévisé spécial primaire
au début de cette émission au sénat le
président socialiste jean pierre bel a
prononcé la traditionnelle allocution
marquant l'ouverture des travaux
parlementaires
ne surchargez pas notre ordre du jour de
projets émotionnel ou de circonstances
at il lancé à l'adresse du gouvernement
enfin cette semaine les partis
politiques organisé leur journée
parlementaire dernière occasion de
recadrer les troupes dans cette année
électorale nous nous intéressons
particulièrement l'ump et europe
ecologie les verts est avec nous pour
commenter l'actualité jean vincent placé
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
la dernière fois que vous êtes venu
commenter l'actualité dans cette
émission sternum de parti europe
ecologie les verts et maintenant vous
avez une casquette supplémentaires salle
de sénateur de l'essonne
arrivé avec la vague rose est donc un
peu verte du 25 septembre dernier
voilà vous siégez depuis deux semaines
plus tôt au fond de l'hémicycle dans
cette courte expérience ya déjà un
moment de la vie sénatoriale qui vous a
particulièrement plu
oui évidemment la première séance qui
est pleine d'émotion il faut le dire
parce que il a l'aspect politique donc
la victoire de la gauche et les
écologistes aussi la grande satisfaction
d'avoir dix sénateurs et sénatrices
écologistes puis évidemment une
satisfaction personnelle qui n'est pas
un aboutissement qui est plutôt un
départ et c'est vrai que de rentrer dans
l'hémicycle le 1er octobre puis
d'écouter un excellent et très beau
discours du doyen d'âge paul vergès
c'était vraiment un moment important où
il bien sûr dans une vie d'homme comme
on dit oui euros offerts et fatigué je
peux vous dire que depuis deux semaines
un autre nana entre la coordination des
sénatrices et sénateurs la coordination
la majorité qu'on est en train de mettre
en place le travail du début du travail
parlementaire moi je suis la commission
des finances
j'ai pris la charge du rapport spécial
sur la sécurité donc ce sont les crédits
de la police et la gendarmerie
elle fait que commencer parce qu'on va
bientôt voter le budget les oui oui on
va je vais intervenir mercredi prochain
sur dexia
je suis et puis on aura des
interventions fortes notamment en début
novembre sur le budget bien sûr et puis
je crois qu'il ya un grand débat mains
dit nicole bricq rapporteur général du
budget sur les prélèvements obligatoires
aux jeunes interviendra également
voilà donc on pourra peut-être que avant
l'élection du président du sénat avait
envisagé d'être également candidat à
cette élection
c'était aussi un moment très important
pour marquer votre territoire
un support pour marquer notre territoire
c'est que nous les écologistes nous
sommes bien sûr avec des alliés des
partenaires on est dans la loyauté mais
on n'est pas dans la vassalisation n'est
pas dans l'inféodation il n'y a pas de
scandale à partir du moment où sur la
deuxième tour on est rassemblée d'avoir
une diversité au premier tour après on a
eu des discussions de la majorité et
jean pierre bel
on avait beaucoup de conviction
notamment sur des convictions
écologiques et de soucis la rénovation
démocratique du sénat de respect aussi
des deux de l'opposition de la volonté
d'ouverture du sénat société apporter
non pas des gages mais des éléments
importants
de future gouvernance de ces jeux non
sincèrement non on ne cherchait pas à
peser certains ont voulu et c'est
peut-être la loi du genre parler de
complément de négociations mais des
négociations et se sont passés assez
vite
les responsabilités sont lourdes à huit
mois de l'élection présidentielle
d'avoir un sénat à gauche et donc il ya
beaucoup de dignité je pensais avoir et
aussi la sobriété de l'éthique le
président bayle on a parlé mercredi dans
son discours
et puis surtout on a à s'opposer bien
sûr les français nous attendent sur
l'opposition à sarkozy et son
gouvernement mais nous attendons
beaucoup sur les propositions et donc ce
travail là il est à faire et je crois
que c'est ça qui est important et va
revenir sur la présence écologiste au
sénat tout à l'heure mais évidemment on
va commencer avec l'actualité qui a
marqué la semaine
le premier tour des primaires
socialistes et le duel qui a suivi alors
on revient d'abord sur l'ambiance du
début de semaine françois hollande en
tête mais un peu déçu le camp aubry qui
garde espoir et un 3e homme arnaud
montebourg bien décidé à jouer les
arbitres en ce lundi en tout cas il ya
des gens à 20 heures la participation
ahmed tazir le pas assuré harlem désir
va annoncer à la presse l'exploit de la
primaire citoyenne un taux de
participation au delà des espérances
socialiste au même moment conclave à
l'assemblée nationale arnaud montebourg
réuni ses troupes
les journalistes sont à l'affût d'une
consigne de vote
c'est une journée passionnante qui sourd
et qui commence appellera à voter pour
aubry ou pour hollande arnaud montebourg
a décidé de ne rien décider
je vais voir maintenant ségolène royal
d'abord parce que le m'a ému cette nuit
et
et par ailleurs je lui suis resté un ami
très proche pendant cette campagne est
par ailleurs elle a défendu des
positions assez proches des miennes
donc je vais lui rendre une visite
amicale à quelques pas de l'assemblée
françois hollande est assailli par les
journalistes celui qui est en tête de la
primaire socialiste ne veut pas que l'on
oublie le message envoyé dimanche soir
par les électeurs de gauche
ils ont voulu surtout être comptable
siège du parti socialiste en début
d'après-midi réunion des soutiens de
martine aubry
le message face à françois hollande la
dame de fer socialiste est plus
rassembleuse s'il n'y avait pas de
différence entre eux et y aurait pas de
primaires donc la différence que sur
laquelle martine aubry veut insister
parce que elle et elle incarne c'est
cette volonté de changement
c'est aussi cette expérience qu'elle a
voilà on va
notre pays est en crise
l'europe est en crise le monde aussi est
dans cette crise là il faut quelqu'un
d'extrêmement soline les deux finalistes
ea fut d'ores et déjà leurs arguments
pour le grand débat qui les opposera
mercredi sur france 2 et le dernier
débat ce face à face a eu lieu mercredi
soir pour tenter de départager les deux
candidats
un débat jugé technique mais crispés
avec quelques escarmouches
morceaux choisis delphine girard je ne
sais pas ce que c'est que la gauche dure
je n'ai pas envie d'ailleurs d'une
gauche dure très franchement on sort de
cinq ans d'une présidence brutale et on
serait nous une candidature sectaire
je ne veux pas quand je parle de gauche
forte la force c'est quand même une
bonne chose c'est comme la solidité ça
veut dire aussi qu'il faut dire les
choses clairement et moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le débat qui
est gênant entre nous c'est le flou je
crois que c'est cela qui peut gêner les
électeurs les si on veut que les
français reprennent confiance en nous
reprenne confiance en la politique
reprenne confiance en la gauche il faut
qu'on dise clairement les choses
je dis oui ou une femme présidente de la
république dont la première mesure jolie
déjà préparé sera de faire voter cette
loi sur l'égalité salariale hommes
femmes
je revendique d'être neuf parce qu'il
faut des solutions neuves
martine tu dis on n'a pas essayé on là
ça n'a pas marché
moi je veux du neuf on regardera alors
jean vincent placé est ce que ça vous a
donné envie de voter pour ce dimanche
n'a pas envie de se battre à du tout
envie de donner envie de voter
en revanche je salue la grande réussite
de cette primaire en
mop ma part j'étais plutôt du condé des
huit hâtif et j'ai eu ce jeu surtout
dans le cours de ceux qui ont vite
erreur de ce débat martine aubry
françois déjà c'est une grande réussite
pour le parti socialiste
un ca avait faim l'a compris jean louis
écoutez je crois que ça va donner tout à
la fois faut relativiser un élan à la
candidature socialiste
après la candidature socialiste il faut
rater s'installe dans l'opinion avec des
propositions de fond et qui seront pas
je suis je pense forcément les scènes
qui ont été dites là parce que quelque
part la responsabilité du congo
socialiste parce que moi je le dis
tranquillement sera d'être le président
ou la présidente en mai prochain si
cette candidature bat nicolas sarkozy
est la vocation évidemment mais j'suis
pas donner de leçon à unifier rassembler
les socialistes en simple en mettant et
il faut que dans le cas de la discussion
que nous aurons sur le pacte de
coalition comme dit cécile duflot au
mois de novembre à payer une réflexion
sur la synthèse des idées écologistes et
socialistes donc cette candidature et
elle a éteint un début
voilà elle est dans un début donc c'est
bien c'est une bonne rampe de lancement
je pense mais je crois que ce sera loin
d'être suffisant s'était pas nécessaire
mais ça ne sera pas suffisant
martine aubry est la plus écolo
compatible à vos yeux vous écologistes
n'ont pas ce qu'elle a dit
a dit ce que nous pensons c'est à dire
que nous avons très bien travaillé que
martine aubry première secrétaire du
parti socialiste qui est une femme de
convictions très fortes avec un
caractère affirmé
mais qui est aussi et qui est aussi plus
tôt mais quelqu'un d'ouverture et de
débats et qui effectivement s'est
beaucoup intéressé aux questions
écologiques à la crise pour la planète
aux questions des ressources naturelles
à la synthèse et questions économiques
et sociales et écologiques
et c'est vrai que sur la question a
sortie du nucléaire il est très clair
donc nous allons d'ailleurs de toute
façon en discuter dès lundi prochain
quoi qu'il arrive avec la première
secrétaire du parti socialiste parce que
je le dis aussi assez tranquillement
moi je suis beaucoup intéressé à ces
primaires après je ne dis pas non plus
que je n'en fais j'en fais une affaire
formidable parce que moi je pense que
c'est important que parent social et
c'est un porte parole pour cette
campagne qui aura vocation à présider la
république mais moi j'attends pas le
sauveur suprême moi j'attends pas celui
qui va nous guider vers un monde
meilleur je pense que celui qui sera
président il a vocation à travailler
avec sa majorité parlementaire oui je
vois que vous êtes surpris de voir ces
palaces vers le travail ensemble mais
en tout cas pour un contrat de
législature c'est ce que vous dites oui
mais c'est ça qui est terrible c'est que
je vois que en plus quelque part vous
êtes tellement habitués à la
personnalisation vous êtes tellement
focalisé là dessus vous êtes tellement
d'un cinquième république faisait
tellement dans les écuries
présidentielles vous serez comblé c'est
plutôt arnaud montebourg alors oui oui
mais oui bien sûr mais nous justement
moi je n'attends pas du tout que ça soit
comme avec monsieur sarkozy on perd à
ses prédécesseurs
messieurs mitterrand et chirac qu' il y
est le président au château ses
conseillers que tout cela dirige à
quelques-uns donne des ordres ministre
impose des projets de loi rapidement
voté par l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat
il faut rien faire ré inventer une autre
forme de démocratie et parlementaires et
une démocratie sociale et j'attends du
président je l' ai déjà dit qu'il soit
président stratège et coordonateur et
pas quelqu'un qui avec lesquels on
serait souvent comme la grosse blind et
martine aubry fait c'qui nommé là et
l'autre iront retrait bien partir du
monde et sociale et se désignent et qu'
il est sera opposé au deuxième tour à
nicolas sarkozy ce que je dis c'est que
il faut qu'il y ait des discussions sur
le fond sur le projet sur les
propositions et qu'on sorte franchement
parce que si ça autant passionné c'est
vrai ça passionné je reconnais et vous
il ya eu un tel focus des médias là
dessus parce que pour vous c'est simple
c'est simple on a les candidats on
essaie de tirer des traits de
personnalité comme ça c'est savoir
autant de la droite non mais il faut pas
que ça soit ces quads story voyez vous
ferez pas qu'on essaye à chaque fois de
dire c'est un celui là dit il joue le
rôle du méchant celui là du mur d'humour
etc
si on pouvait revenir là maintenant
après cette primaire sur le débat de
fond quel sur quel sera le projet du
candidat socialiste quel sera plus
précisément le projet de la candidate
des écologistes
la discussion avec nos amis du front de
gauche l'opposition résolue face à la
droite la façon de travailler en
cohérence dans l'unité dans la diversité
dans les gauches les gauche communiste
et radicale et gauche sociale-démocrate
les gauche écologiste balade moi c'est
ça l'intérêt s'est vivement ces
primaires ça termine oui
face à l'impasse au haut et aux
discussions de fond aux chaussures avec
de coalition et puis bien sûr la
préparation du premier tour parce qu'il
ya quand même un premier tour avant le
deuxième un mode arnaud montebourg donc
on a vu dans les halles les ralliements
de cet entre deux tours qui était
largement profitable à françois hollande
ségolène royal manuel valls
puis ce vendredi arnaud montebourg à
titre personnel là c'est la gauche de la
gauche qui est rejoint un peu la social
démocratie ça vous étonne c'est cohérent
au moins je serai pas de commentaires
sur les ralliements déjà lutte les
termes n'est pas terrible on devrait
plutôt dire soutien et puis chacun fait
ce qu'il veut
voilà un vrai soutien
non moi je les dis d'ailleurs la plupart
des militants écologistes ont plutôt
voté réellement d'ailleurs ce que eux
aussi ont été intéressés par sa haine je
le reconnais bien volontiers parce que
nous on n'a pas donné on ne participe
pas au niveau de la direction d'europe
écologie les verts et des grands élus du
mouvement après c'est évident que comme
on est plutôt tradition libertaire et je
trouve ça tout à fait normal
on n'a ni interdite ni poussé donc ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya eu aussi
un mouvement où les militants
écologistes se sont dit on va aller
voter le 22 avril pour eva joly et on va
participer pour choisir ceux liés au
sexe au deuxième tour donc il y sont
massivement allez je pense que la très
grande majorité a voté pour martine
aubry il faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont et de façon significative
beaucoup certains ont voté pour arnaud
montebourg d'ailleurs sont plutôt les
thèmes de la rénovation démocratique la
6è et puis aussi le lien avec eux là
l'idée de démondialisation qui a
intéressé les écologistes alors c'est
amusant parce que je les dis à mes
propres camarades je leur ai dit c'est
bien parce que ça vous intéresse à 6e
république vous avez peut-être voté
aussi pour le plus pro nucléaire mais
candidat socialiste arnaud et provenant
celui qui est le plus attaché au
maintien
du nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
voilà donc voilà frei ont les uns et les
autres ne sont pas une contradiction
près donc ce n'est pas très bien ce
n'est pas bien grave
démondialisation va vous faire écouter
ce qu'en pense jean françois copé celui
qui va être le faiseur de roi pour le
second tour c'est arnaud montebourg or
le problème des faiseurs de roi c'est
qu'on doit les courtiser les faiseurs de
roi donc voilà qu arnaud montebourg va
devenir de la part des deux finalistes
madame aubry monsieur hollande l'homme
le plus important de la terre avec
évidemment à la clé tout le programme
d'arnaud montebourg qui est ce concept
fou je crois qu'il faut appeler les
choses par leur nom de la
démondialisation qui fait hurler de rire
le monde entier
alors le concept fou qui fait hurler de
rire le monde entier
est ce que finalement c'est pas un
écueil et pour le et pour les
socialistes et même pour vous
écologistes d'adhérer comme ça à des
tests qui sont à la gauche de la gauche
et qui sous certains aspects sont assez
peu réaliste
non je crois pas parce que le bon ça
fait partie des élections et là-dessus
jean françois copé a raison c'est vrai
que dans l'entre-deux tours d'une
élection va toujours chercher celles et
ceux qui ont été éliminés au premier qui
peuvent apporter un soutien après tout à
la fois ça fait partie du jeu
d'alliances c'est tout à la fois je
pense qu'il c'est pareil il faut
relativiser puisque les françaises et
français aujourd'hui ils sont de plus en
plus autonome et tant mieux d'ailleurs
ils n'attendent pas ni la parole suprême
diffusé sur facebook ni les consignes de
vote les gens ils sont surtout dans cet
électorat qui a participé aux primaires
ils sont beaucoup sur internet c'est un
public très informés et ils se
prononceront en leur âme et conscience
comme on dit donc je crois que c'est pas
très important
après la question la démondialisation
moi je n'aime pas trop le terme parce
que le terme fait très agressif
vis-à-vis de l'action extérieure
très identitaire fait très
protectionniste même si pour le coup
moi je suis tenant de la gauche
économique la régulation de l'impôt dont
moi je n'ai pas besoin de réhabiliter
j'ai le destine pour l'impôt quand il
est juste et progressif
après il ya le rôle du service public
elle prône de l'investissement public
pour ddd grands investissements futurs
est important sur les transports
collectifs soit énergies renouvelables
donc voilà donc sur cette thématique là
de la régulation du gouvernement
économique y compris européens je crois
que c'est important qu'il y ait
différents acteurs qui porte cette idée
plutôt qu'une idée de social-libéralisme
demain du marché et c'est donc c'est des
tests qui pourraient rentrer dans votre
cuisine dans son mental et kiki ce
modèle se rapprochera de jean luc
mélenchon aussi mais où c'est il se
présente tout ce débat là est
intéressant parce que jean luc mélenchon
lui il porte la question la
planification écologique alors c'est
pareil le mot plantes et ferait un petit
peu il a des connotations négatives
notamment par le passé et dans
l'histoire pas de notre pays plus que ça
mais dans d'autres pays et c'est vrai
que planification
démondialisation il y à un manque de
dynamique je pense quand même vers
l'ouverture extérieur en revanche et je
répète le fait qu'on soit plus dans une
lutte est contre les libertés excessive
aux banques
les luttes contre les libertés excessive
de l'industrie le fait que les normes
environnementales et sociales sont peu
respectés et que aujourd'hui le seul
ordre international qui existe en vrai
c'est celui mondiale du commerce
alors qu'il n'y en a pas vraiment de des
solidarités il y en a pas non plus nos
réactions mondiales l'environnement que
nous nous voulons les écologistes voilà
ce monde là très sincèrement il est à
changer il est à réguler et donc il ya
des tests qui se rapprochent gens ont
compris le gagnant 2 ou la gagnante de
dimanche soir aura bien intégré ce à la
demande de régulation d'intervention
publique
la gauche demande plus de justice plus
solidarité de lutte est vraiment camp
nou contre l'ordre établi
c'est une demande très forte encore un
niveau parmi pas seulement les plus
défavorisés mais y compris celles et
ceux qui aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
questions acérées qui veulent vraiment
changer le système on a beaucoup de
questions qu'on va aller assez vite
le groupe du parti socialiste aussi
s'est réunie cette semaine au sénat
les résultats des primaires était bien
sûr sur toutes les lèvres françois
hollande savait y compte de nombreux
soutiens vous allez le voir avec ce
reportage de fabrice qu'une et pour les
sénateurs le résultat final sera quand
même très serré réunion de groupe ce
matin les sénateurs socialistes se
risque au jeu des pronostics avant le
second tour de la primaire
pour beaucoup le duel est très ouvert et
le petit jeu des ralliements serait loin
d'être une science exacte
dans une élection d'un type tout à fait
nouveau je ne suis pas certaine que le
comportement des électeurs aille dans le
sens des reports commandés par leur chef
de file
pour le porte parole de manuel valls la
question ne se pose plus son chef de
file s'est clairement prononcé en faveur
de françois hollande
nous avons dès hier
sans équivoque les équipes de campagne
de françois hollande et nous jouerons à
leurs côtés et tous ensemble notre parti
pour qu'il y ait dimanche prochain le
laisser sa rassemblement dont françois
hollande
les négocier quelque chose elles valent
c'est un homme qui ne négocie rien il
fait des choses pour être utile et c'est
ce qu'il a démontré là où certains
disent king s'est prononcée rapidement
c'est la preuve qu'il n'a rien négocier
autour de la table les partisans de
françois hollande sont largement
majoritaires
une situation pas toujours confortable
pour les soutiens de la maire de lille
alors même si tous s'en défendent le
résultat de dimanche conditionnera
certainement l'ambiance des prochaines
réunions de groupe
alors c'est bien jean vincent placé le
résultat de dimanche peut donner une
dynamique forte ou pas tout dépend si
c'est serré ou pas vous attendez d'eux
une élection serrée je pense que déjà la
dynamique existe je le dis très
franchement et sincèrement et je pense
que le résultat sera serré mais je sais
pas bien grand vent il ya dans la vie
politique a des résultats est celui qui
gagne d'une voix il a gagné après il
leur âge de nîmes et je compte aller
c'est ciment conseillé le candidat
socialiste candidat socialiste il aura
rassemblé les siens il aura à s'ouvrir
sur les partenaires et il aura à
s'opposer très fortement et y compris
faire en sorte qu'il sait dynamique et
pour le premier tour et pour le deuxième
tour je nous ne serons pas contre le
candidat socialiste ne seront bien à
côté
juste une petite question finale sur ce
dossier quand vous voyez ces primaires
là vous n'avez pas l'impression d'avoir
un peu raté les vôtres
je suis vous dire alors je suis c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être mon côté
dinosaures de la politique même si je
suis jeune d'âge mais je vais vous moi
je le dis franchement parce que tout le
monde dit c'est formidable mais je dis
c'est très bien donc je veux même pas
mais moi j'aime l'histoire
j'aime l'histoire et puis j'ai je crois
j'ai un peu de culture politique je
crois que le seul qui a été élu
président la république à gauche était
désigné au deuxième sous-sol de
l'assemblée nationale en candidat unique
en décembre 1981 il s'appelle françois
mitterrand alors moi donc ça vous
n'allez peut réinventer tout et essayer
de ressembler à fond aux états unis et
faire vraiment de la place est conféré
le maire non je suis pas je ne pense que
ça a été bien fait vous voyez je suis
pas je peux pas dire c'est un échec et
où je dis c'est une réussite ça a été
bien fait très franchement les
françaises et les français ils attendent
des réponses sur l'emploi sur le
logement sur la santé sur l'éducation de
leurs enfants sur l'écologie évidemment
sa démocratie donc on va peut-être pas
leur parler pendant des siècles de
savoir combien il y avait des bureaux de
vote
comment il fallait y aller et c'est donc
je pense que la dynamique elle sera là
c'est voilà le résultat je pense qu'il
sera serré parce que ça me paraît assez
évident au vu des résultats du premier
tour et lui aussi la proximité
de l'une et de l'autre sur le plan
idéologique allez on va reprendre le fil
normal de la semaine lundi c'était vos
journées parlementaires
oui les journées donc d'europe écologie
les verts retrouvailles à rambouillet
donc pour les députés et sénateurs
d'europe écologie les verts dans une
ambiance bonne évidemment après le bon
score des sénatoriales
jérémy hartmann jardin dès ce matin en
arrivant à rambouillet le rouge était
plus que jamais de rigueur pour eva joly
mais pas question d'oublier le vert au
lendemain du premier tour de la primaire
citoyenne
la candidate écologiste à la
présidentielle met déjà la pression à
françois hollande et martine aubry
c'est vrai que martine aubry sur le
nucléaire est est plus en avance plus
proche de nos positions de françois
hollande
mais cela ne veut pas dire que françois
hollande ne bougerait pas sur ses
positions
un rapport de force où les écologistes
essaie d'exister face à leurs
partenaires de gauche les socialistes
invités de marque de ces journées
parlementaires d'europe écologie avec le
front de gauche
ou comment ne pas être totalement
éclipsé par l'actualité de la primaire
il n'y a pas grand monde qui parle
aujourd'hui dit d'ailleurs nicolas
sarkozy ou de l'ump ou du parti
communiste soit peu d'europe écologie
les verts c'est le temps de la primaire
qui a focalisé c'est comme ça c'est
confiant les écologistes leçon aux
sénatoriales de fin septembre
dix élus verts sont rentrés à la haute
assemblée alors pour 2012 la patronne du
parti rêve déjà d'une nouvelle gauche
plurielle mais un peu relooké au moment
de la gauche plurielle il y avait un
gros parti socialiste est plein de
petits satellites a qui ont distribué un
sucre chacun son tour
là on prépare les choses en amont et on
l'a fait manière transparente avec les
autres formations politiques on a dit au
front de gauche si vous voulez
participer avec nous vous êtes les
bienvenus c'est pas leur souhait je peux
le comprendre enfin ce même si je le
regrette je peux le comprendre mais
c'est quelque chose de très ouvert en
revanche ça nous engage tous ça nous
engage tous durablement pendant 5
ce nouvel attelage de gauche dépendra
surtout du résultat de la présidentielle
un scrutin qui n'a jamais beaucoup
réussi aux écologistes leur meilleur
score date de 2002 noël mamère n'avait
pas dépassé les 6%
donc on a vu vous y étiez bonne ambiance
vous confirmez oui alors il va donc y
avoir des négociations laver dans le
sujet est ce que dans un premier temps
l'a déjà on entend déjà à fait eva joly
si on a l'impression qu'elle a un petit
peu disparu messages extraits vraiment
ça me fait je trouve que je vous trouve
fabuleux
moi je vous reprocherai pas de faire
votre travail je comprends que là il y
avait le feu qu'ils souhaitent primaire
et tout mais c'est vraiment je n'ai même
pas c'est l'hôpital qui se moque de la
charité quoi c'est c'est eh
l'ump sait que pendant un mois vous ne
parlez que des primaires après plus de
dix tabou mais quand même on n'entend
pas parler de vous alors nous on bosse
on fait plein de réunions au travail à
des experts ont fait les journées
parlementaires on est sur le terrain on
fait des déplacements on fait des
réunions sauf que voilà après c'est vous
qui choisissez aussi comment mais jean
vincent placé le plus sérieusement ce
que je lis la vie elle va à son rythme
et oui c'est votre rythme pareil comme
pour les primaires moi je veux dire on
va relativiser tout ça
nous sous notre point fort c'est qu'on a
un très bon projet et que nous sommes
les seuls à parler d'écologie en vrai
dire que tout le monde parle d'écologie
globalement dans son discours à la new
on en parle beaucoup on et experts sur
le sujet on en fait dans les mairies
dans les régions on porte le combat
de choi dit la synthèse la protection la
planète des solidarités la justice
la 6ème république oui je pense que
plutôt tout va bien eva joly est sur le
terrain nous avons très très bonne
entente entre la candidate et le parti
sa secrétaire nationale
voilà donc on fera les temps de
nécessaire et je vais vous dire ce qui
va compter pour nous comme d'ailleurs à
chaque élection présidentielle c'est
d'être à fond dans les six dernières
semaines
au moment où la cristallisation s'opère
et là on va essayer d'intéresser encore
plus les françaises et les français à
nos thèmes écologiques alors si tout va
mieux on va passer au mardi les
sénateurs sont venus nombreux écouter le
nouveau président jean pierre bel
c'était la traditionnelle allocution
marquant l'ouverture des travaux
parlementaires et jean pierre bel
demande au gouvernement de ne pas
surcharger
l'ordre du jour de projets émotionnel ou
de circonstance un plaidoyer sur la
nécessaire relance de la
décentralisation écouter le gouvernement
ne dispose plus que de la moitié du
temps parlementaire
il doit en tirer toutes les conséquences
et éviter de surcharger notre ordre du
jour de projets de loi émotionnels ou de
circonstance alors jean vincent placé
quand jean-pierre mais elle parle de ses
projets de loi émotionnels
il dénonce bien sûr les faits divers une
loi qu appliquer par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui en tout cas selon les termes
de jean pierre bel vous vous y
opposeraient quoi qu'il arrive mais
c'est la position des verts aujourd'hui
oui je crois que
l'intérêt du bicamérisme du fait qu'il y
ait deux chambres c'est que la première
évidemment l'assemblée nationale qui ai
compris a le dernier mot reflète la
majorité à un moment donné du pays et le
rôle de senna nous nous voulons plutôt
un sénat d'aidé région des monts pas
parler de ça aujourd'hui
il doit être plus dans les grands enjeux
stratégiques et y compris sur des
questions très porteur personnalisé sur
sur l'euthanasie sur la bioéthique sont
des grands sujets comme ça de société eh
bien il doit y avoir une vision pas plus
paisible mais pas non plus pondéré il
faut on pourrait vous dire ça avec
beaucoup plus de recul avec une volonté
de légiférer y compris dans le calme
jamais dans l'urgence pas dans la
précipitation et faire en sorte que moi
je le souhaite bien sûr un sénat
d'opposition mais à senna utiles sur les
projets de loi parce que on a vu depuis
quatre cinq ans ce que pourquoi
aujourd'hui senna a perdu sa majorité
monsieur larcher n'est plus président
c'est un homme respectable sur marché
mais enfin c'était à senna godillots
terres qui ont été au pouvoir ils nous
cogner dessus en faisant de
l'obstruction
et quand la droite est au pouvoir et son
godillots donc c'est sûr que personne
n'a compris l'utilité du sénat aussi
bien les français et les françaises mais
aussi les grands électeurs donc voilà où
demandé et nous nous avons à restaurer
l'image du sénat à faire de la politique
autrement à faire de la législation
autrement et pas faire en sorte qu'on
soit sur la couture du pantalon oui
c'est valable pour le camp socialiste
mais c'est aussi valable pour le
président sarkozy parce qu'il ya 4-5
communicants qui se sont réunis de la
petite cellule autour de monsieur
sarkozy ne monsieur buisson le matin et
donc on légifère dans les dix jours
en oubliant toutes les lois je ne sais
pas si vous vous souvenez qu'on nous
parlait un moment de la fameuse prime de
1000 euros pour je ne sais qui je ne
sais quoi je ne sais quel moment est-ce
qu'on en parle aujourd'hui bien non et
pourtant pendant huit jours on ne m'a
posé que cette question là parce que
présent à république et cette lubie et
ses conseillers on peut plus travailler
comme ça dans ce pays une petite pièce
soissons le le groupe que vous voulez
conseiller au sénat a priori la règle
sexe et 15 sénateurs pour avoir un
groupe
pourquoi réclamer 10
pour presse mais moi je réclame rien
mais d'une part le président du sénat
l'a annoncé dans son discours mardi je
crois que sa volonté
s'il est un privilège c'est sa volonté
sur la précision du sénat non vous savez
ça alors c'est ce qui est bien ici c'est
que je crois que même tout le monde
s'est mis au fait que c'était un peu
immuable ici donc il faut faire comme
avant se dit souvent me dit ah mais non
c'est pas possible que tu dis parce
qu'au sénat on fait comme ça etc
mais personne n'a jamais dit ça
d'ailleurs ces journalistes qui disent
agir non mais en plus c'est relayé c'est
à dire que c'est un truc faux départ et
le truc faux et relayés pendant huit dix
jours mais bref ça c'est autre chose
mais pour en revenir au sujet je crois
que ce qui est important c'est d'avoir
la diversité politique un moment les
groupes au sénat était à 20 puis à 15 je
crois que c'est un progrès démocratique
d'aller à 10 à l'assemblée nationale
d'ailleurs à la demande des communistes
c'était à 30 puis 20 puis 15 ils sont
et ce n'est pas une mesure de
circonstance ou parce que moi j'aurais
exigé je crois que c'est une volonté
partagée de la majorité et de son
président le président du sénat de faire
en sorte qu'ils aient plus de démocratie
plus de débats et plus de diversité au
sein de la haute assemblée jean vincent
placé vous aviez dit je ne veux pas d'un
scénario est bien écouter ce sénateur
joël labbé a écouté plus robert va lui
apprendre à leur élan il ya quelques
jours je suis entré ici avec beaucoup
d'émotion dans cette grande et haute
maison si chargé de l'histoire et il me
dit il m'est venu en tête
une douce petite musique portant ces
mots très forts for the times they are a
changing c'était bob dylan c'était les
années 60 ces mêmes années 60 où
commencer les travaux du club de rome
et bien voilà bob dylan au sénat c'est
ça le changement c'est bien je suis sûr
je pense que ça va de la première fois
que bob dylan est cité au sénat et c'est
joël labbé notre sénateur du morbihan
c'est quelqu'un de formidable s'était
donné le ton en tout cas oui mais je
sais pas attention parce que
c'est bien bob dylan mais ce qu'on veut
faire c'est tout à la fois des choses
sur les symboles et bob dylan voilà il
est temps que sur bob dylan c'est à dire
que l'on parlait fort l'écologie c'est
d'intérêt de la commission écologique
nous allons créer dans le prochain la
prochaine modification du règlement
intérieur et c'est aussi une vraie
rénovation démocratique du sénat parce
qu'il y à un moment on est enfin
d'ailleurs regardé par les françaises et
les français au sénat et je peux vous
dire qu'on nous attend quand même au
tournant et on a intérêt à être utile
beaucoup plus sobre et beaucoup plus
éthique aussi allez on va passer au
mercredi avec un sujet qui va vous
intéresser
jean vincent placé c'est lassant à
l'assemblée l'unanimité contre le
bisphénol a c'est un phénomène rare une
proposition de loi socialiste adoptée à
l'unanimité par les députés le texte
instaure l'interdiction du bisphénol a
dans les contenants alimentaires un
perturbateur endocrinien qui avait déjà
été interdit pour la fabrication des
biberons
on écoute le député gérard bapt
maintenant le bisphénol sera interdite à
premier à partir du 1er janvier 2014 dès
le 1er janvier 2013
en ce qui concerne les enfants de moins
de 3 ans ce qui existe d'ailleurs déjà
au danemark
le fait de produire
sans bisphénol ou 101 autres
perturbateurs endocriniens va
représenter un avantage commercial pour
les firmes qui pourront les
commercialiser donc c'est là dessus que
je compte pour que le mouvement en étant
donné très rapidement nous trouvions la
plupart des aliments y compris en
conserve ce qui est le plus difficile
sans bisphénol parce qu'il faudra
ensuite passer aux phtalates wallace
portable alors le sénat suivra sûrement
des députés je suis très content qui
évidemment s'il ya unanimité
je me souviens que quand cécile duflot
était jeune porte parole notre mouvement
elle avait dit je crois la première il
ya sept huit ans dans une indifférence
générale donc comme quoi on a raison de
porter oui oui on sait quoi d'autre
autant d'aces et l'aspartame par exemple
les grands dossiers non mais le moi je
suis pas spécialiste précis des des
différents médicaments qu'il faut qu'il
faut supprimer ou de ski de ski
souhaitable de faire don je le dis très
franchement après dans tous ces dossiers
le principe de précaution doit
s'appliquer
et c'est vrai que là on a une énorme
progression avec des lobbys industriels
qui sont là notamment les lobbys
pharmaceutiques ou les lobbys agro
alimentaire et nous le le débat que nous
avons porté tout seul au début mais
renforcé maintenant c'est évidemment la
relation entre la santé environnement et
c'est une idée qui progresse et je m'en
réjouis très franchement rien pas de
miracle en revanche l'assemblée sur une
autre proposition de loi socialiste
l'assemblée car tu es rejeté un texte
interdisant l'exploration et
l'exploitation du gaz de schiste sous
toutes ses formes
pour l'instant seule la méthode de la
fracturation hydraulique extrêmement
polluante est interdite
jean vincent placé cela peut être un
nouveau combat au sénat une interdiction
totale s'auto oui oui nous allons nous
portons l'interdiction totale de
l'exploitation bien sûr mais de
l'exploration et on voit bien que
bon je reviendrai pas sur le fait que ce
soit monsieur borloo qui en partant et
autoriser tous ses permis
je me suis réjouie que monsieur jacob
soit devenu assez écolo sont tous sous
la pression de ses de ses électeurs dans
ce cas là par hasard
oui en fait j'ai constaté qu'il ya 15
permis sont en cours mais à chaque fois
qu'est quoi sarkozy va dans un endroit
où il y a des permis en cours
il vient il les arrête donc les arrêter
dans le gard dans son déplacement la nar
et et 3,1 encore 15 en cours sur
directement les gaz de schiste en encre
64 également sur au delà d'autres formes
de livres au carbure nous c'est
l'interdiction totale que nous voulons
l'interdiction totale aussi de
l'exploration parce que enfin et je
crois que c'est bien parce que j'avais
discuté de ça et christian jacob l'avait
quand il avait laissé propres électeurs
qu'il est devant sa permanence c'est
qu'ils votaient en plus
traditionnellement à droite il a enfin
compris qui effectivement c'est
compliqué d'expliquer aux gens que de
balancer à 400-500 mètres des millions
de mètres cubes d'eau avec des produits
chimiques et du sable expliqué que ça ça
ne touche pas la nappe phréatique moi je
leur souhaite bon courage à tous ces
gens là donc en plus l'exploitation n'a
que peu d'intérêt y compris sur le plan
économique dans la mesure où ce n'est
pas même pas bénéficiaire donc il faut
arrêter tout ça il faut l'arrêter en
france en europe il faut l'arrêter est
compris dans le monde en titre d'autres
méthodes moins polluantes s'étant jamais
que la fracturation et la porte
c'est un peu le même débat qu'il faut
rapprocher de la sortie du nucléaire
c'est que on sait que tout ça va
s'arrêter un moment ou un autre auteur
est ce qu on veut continuer à forer sur
le gaz de schiste est ce qu on veut
aller en arctique et antarctique
chercher encore du pétrole
ou est ce qu'on veut faire en sorte que
la france qui a beaucoup innové dans le
monde ont été les premiers sur la
démocratie on a été les premiers sur la
démocratie sociale et solidarité et
syndicats est-ce qu'on pourrait être
encore digne de notre histoire
être en avance pour l'europe pour le
monde et pour la planète être les
premiers des écologistes et y compris je
dis aux entreprises vous allez gagner de
l'argent en faisant ça plutôt que de
subir le poids des industriels
américains et russes ou chinois qui de
toute façon à un moment sont plus
concurrentiel que nous sur ce dossier
voilà donc tout à la fois c'est mieux et
tout à la fois ça pourra servir
l'industrie française on est quand même
là dessus pendant très très en retard
sur tout on mérite ça sera un des enjeux
de la campagne au profit
l'enjeu global de des énergies oui bien
sûr parce que le fener g tic
c'est le débat du productivisme parce
qu'à un moment pourquoi on produit
beaucoup c'est parce que l'énergie et à
bas coût
ensuite il ya le problème des transports
donc c'est toujours le même problème
quand on peut transporter à bas coûts eh
bien on a une économie mondialisée qui
est ridicule où on fait dix mille bande
pour donner un kiwi à quelqu'un pour le
pour le manger etc
fabrice et toute cette logique là
globalement d'une forme de régulation et
de formes de relocalisation que nous
voulons avoir avec une dynamique sur les
énergies renouvelables avec une
dynamique sur l'agriculture de proximité
et puis que globalement aussi en soi un
moment porteur de sens pourquoi on fait
de la politique c'est pour rapprocher
les gens et pas pour les opposer et ça
va être aussi un moment ce grand temps
de l'élection présidentielle où j'espère
qu'on sortira des histoires des grands
débats passionnants entre chef de l'état
et jean pierre raffarin sur la taxe des
parcs d'attractions parce que on réussit
maintenant à faire des focus 2 3 4 jours
sur 90 millions pour la taxe sur les
parcs d'attraction
alors que je crois très sincèrement que
les françaises et les français nous
attendent sur une mobilisation autour
d'un grand projet et de valeur pour la
france on pourra revenir sur le gaz de
schiste lui la création avait obtenu la
création d'une commission sur le
développement durable ça peut être
éventuellement un de ces combats avaient
bien sûr on était quand même ici au
sénat alors que la révision
constitutionnelle d'ailleurs de monsieur
sarkozy permettait de créer cette
commission
on était une des dernières assemblées en
europe dans les démocraties occidentales
alpes avoir de commission qui
s'intéressent à l'impact notamment chez
lui mais je n'ai pas obtenu la
présidence
en vérité on ne la non
or on a mangé on nous l'a un peu
proposée d'ailleurs faut être très franc
je vous dis la vérité
sauf que comme justement ont subi assez
dry riz de votre part sur le groupe a
dit surtout ça on a voulu montrer et ses
très sincères de notre part que nous
nous intéressons à la question de fond
et qu'on ne voulait pas créer une
commission pour avoir un poste qui eût
été votre première réaction je pense et
donc on me dit que ça sera un candidat
logique cependant oui et non c'est à
dire que nous ne voulons pas comme l'a
dit cécile duflot être dans les sucres
environnementaux c'est à dire que
l'écologie c'est global et c'est aussi
dans les affaires culturelles dans la
recherche en éducation et je suis
vraiment très content ça me permet de le
dire que marie christine blandin sur la
première présidente de commission d'une
assemblée parlementaire qui soit écolo
allez olla ce jeudi à quai les journées
parlementaires de l'ump
alors ça se passe à saint cyr sur loire
et les dirigeants de l'ump ont une
difficile mission exister face à la
primaire socialiste et surtout à
remobiliser leurs troupes après la
défaite aux sénatoriales séance de
motivation collective c'est un sujet de
jérôme rabin opération reconquête pour
l'ump à saint-cyr-sur-loire la primaire
socialiste bientôt finie il faut occuper
le champ médiatique et repartir au
combat
le mot d'ordre c'est la mobilisation
générale voilà notre
grand round de primaire est maintenant
totalement terminée on va pouvoir enfin
travailler après deux mois où on a pris
beaucoup de coups maintenant on va
remonter à cheval pour mener cette
bataille le parti doit se serrer les
coudes
oubliez les dissidences aux sénatoriales
la majorité joue l'unité je suis un
militant exemplaire depuis 40 ans votre
présence est la preuve du grand
rassemblement pour lancer la campagne
une seule et unique si pour tous les
participants le parti socialiste et ses
primaires omniprésente à le parti
socialiste a eu la chance de pouvoir
occuper l'espace médiatique
quelquefois de manière un peu creuse
mais en tout cas on a vu que les
socialistes qui débattre entre eux on a
presque l'impression que le débat
politique se résume aux socialistes on
les a beaucoup entendu parler on n'a pas
entendu propositions on n'a rien vu sur
le fond sinon beaucoup d'erreurs
beaucoup de danger sur la fiscalité
notamment
et puis on voit bien il est temps que
cette campagne primaire s'arrête parce
que ça vole bas entre eux en ce moment
en revanche pas question de s'attarder
sur la création d'un courant humaniste
cette semaine à l'ump qui pourraient
éventuellement faire naître les
divisions c'est bien connu rien de mieux
qu'un ennemi commun pour resserrer les
rangs avant le vrai combat finalement
etnies un peu la même chose que vous
c'est ouf les primaires socialistes se
terminera enfin pour exister mais je
voulais dire on est on est on est serein
donc on va faire un autre rythme et puis
on va intensifier après noël et puis on
attend suffira après en être et sans
faux semblants de vecteur d'une campagne
violente venant de l'ump notamment
risque bout si vous craignez cette
campagne jeu oui oui je le crains parce
que le climat politique est très
détériorée entre la majorité et
l'opposition dans la majorité
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y a parti
majoritaire aux abois après les échecs
municipaux 2008 européens régionaux
cantonaux la perte du sénat qui est tout
de même on s'y habitue peut-être en fait
depuis deux semaines enfin c'est pas une
déflagration dans le champ politique
français et on sait la capacité du clan
sarkozy à vouloir s'accrocher au pouvoir
oui effectivement tout cas partie de la
vie c'est la contre attaque de l'ump
nous on veut rester sur le fond et je
crois que d'ailleurs je le dis aux amis
socialistes ils ont été plutôt digne
responsable dans le débat pendant un
mois
il ya évidemment quelques petites
escarmouches d'arrière garde cette
semaine mais ça c'est assez naturel et
ça a été plutôt digne et nous on doit
avoir cette dignité l'a7 ce sens des
responsabilités sur le projet sur les
propositions sur les idées et puis vont
laisser à la droite c'est la méthode
mais c'est sûr que quand dans l'ambiance
karachi
bourgi takieddine voilà c'est cesser la
politique dont on veut plus tout ça
enfin on va finir de façon un petit peu
plus légères vos bureaux où doivent être
le nombre du musée du luxembourg je
crois vous avez peut-être l'occasion en
vous promenant d'aller voir cette
exposition celle de paul cézanne qui
veulent ouvrir donc au musée du
luxembourg 77 en oeuvre du peintre du
19e siècle comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images
les gens rassemblés vous aurez peut-être
un petit peu de temps cette exposition
ferme ses portes fin février mais la
discussion
on a une petite visite de prévue la
semaine prochaine la semaine d'après oh
oui oui voilà et c'est évidemment
ouverts au public viennent bien
évidemment sur voila merci d'être sur
cette émission commenter l'actualité de
la semaine
les comptes à nos michael on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine et va même y en a
marre week-end